it's a go we're gonna go we're gonna
start doing the podcast all right and
acting we'll start doing it the podcast
and acting and already done like we like
each other and you're listening to the
dollop on the all things comedy Network
oh good one day thank you this is an
American history podcast for each week I
Dave Anthony read a story from American
history to my friend
a Gareth Reynolds who has no idea what
the topic is going to be about how are
you normal fine
regular Sunday yeah nothing interesting
happen to you today
nothing Church out of the ordinary went
to church spoke at church obviously
Church course you're saying Church you
love a signature clap sang a church yep
yeah after church brunch for the
pastor's okay you know that passage day
we were cleaned up with church yeah a
lot of us just helped stuck around
pitched in that's why was it so messy we
had a really crazy brunch we were doing
a lot of crazies there's I mean waffle
maker and they had was shaped like
Mickey Mouse so those were going so we
ran out of battery way and then yeah
after that Holmes you go home went home
did Bible study then when washing TV
watch TV went to the bedroom
mm-hmm took a nap got up God after the
night God up then came here nothing in
between didn't watch anything on TV no
one believed - oh the Packers game Oh
watch the Packers game yeah oh I know
just that it was it was a good good well
fought well fought battle again I mean
it was nice to see the Packers pick up
what seemed like three third downs on
the final drive that was Mike McCarthy
would have done which would have been
handing the ball off three times and
leave them with two minutes and ten
seconds to go okay you know score and
win the game alright let's not this is
not the time to bag on
McCarthy all right I don't know at all I
don't know him personally he's a friend
he's a friend and then I watched I
watched part of the other game and I saw
a guy do a fake punt when he was up at
24 points on his own 30 yard line and I
don't know who that coach is or what
he's doing but he shouldn't be in charge
of a team whatever so we have a lot of
dates coming up for live dollops yeah I
did not have for some reason the Detroit
show in the Minneapolis show were not up
on the webpage they're up now so if you
were wondering why that was not a thing
it was cuz I'm a dummy there we go
ability so we're gonna be in February
we'll be in San Jose San Francisco then
we'll be at the just for last Vancouver
Festival and then we'll be in Salt Lake
City Denver Royal Oak Michigan
Minneapolis Cincinnati Pittsburgh
Cleveland Seattle two shows Portland two
shows oh we added a second show in Salt
Lake City sorry so now two shows in Salt
Lake City Houston Austin Dallas Oklahoma
City Nashville st. Louis Kansas City Des
Moines West Palm Beach tampa orlando
louisville indianapolis there's a lot of
dates I never wanted to go to Florida
and now with looking at ticket sales I
was right
were you yeah I have not looked at the
ticket sales for that one I will say I
was shocked when you decided we would go
and then look at them well you know I
love I love you love the painting
Orlando Orlando is like Orlando in
Jacksonville the rest of it I don't like
it makes sense does the those are the
ones I also have some dates David I'll
be in Australia July 21st through
February first everything is fine there
I'll be doing stand-up you can go to my
website Gareth Reynolds comm for tickets
and all that stuff there's some tickets
available for some shows but not a lot
so go there
and then some of the money that is made
there will be going to help the koalas
out and then February 7th through the
9th I'll be at the Irvine improv
February 27th through March 1st I'll be
rooster teeth feathers and then April 24
through 26 the Denver improv April 30th
through May 3rd the Pittsburgh improv
May 28th through the 31st the Rallye
improv you can go to my website for
those tickets some of those tickets
might not be up yet but that just means
they have been posted and they will be
eventually so I'm thinking I will donate
some money to the port Meharry koala
hospital is what I'm thinking
we're they're doing good stuff with the
koalas who are getting [ __ ] up
yeah because what's happening there is
great just a billion animals yeah yes so
uh after that great note
we're brought to you by helix sleep so
uh so I sleep I sleep facedown what yeah
I'm a facedown sleep I sleep down you
sleep facedown
well my face isn't down but yeah I sleep
on my stomach okay that's okay but you
sleep no I don't sleep face face down
yeah like I'm like a person who's
collapsed yeah it looked like somebody
all right hon so I'm gonna hit it Dave
so I got it yeah
thank you meet me oh that's my key it's
not a brand new mattress
okay it's a helix mattress so here's how
it works
you go to it you go to the helix website
you take a quiz yeah like two minutes
it's not an hour or anything and then it
matches your body type and sleep
preferences pick the picks the mattress
yeah right so I like I like a medium
mattress which really it is getting it's
crazy how accurate you know you can get
there really is yeah so I got the one
that was right for my my facedown
sleeping sure the shot of the guy hey
were like on the level of like normal to
psychotic where do you fall obviously
the psychotic heavy psychotic that's
right so they've been awarded the number
one best overall sleeve mattress it
comes in a box it's the same you open it
up it puffs up if you put on the bed and
sleeping like a baby now yeah I'm
literally sleeping like a baby yeah very
comfortable swaddled it's just yeah it
just it just works okay I don't know
what to say I might you know it takes my
weight
gives a little back you know I'm talking
about but anyway super calm for my wife
super come everyone's are very happy
okay it's just the two of you helix luxe
is what I have okay
the luxe yeah I went big time so the
number one overall mattress pick of 2019
by GQ and Wired magazine look just go to
helix comm slash dollop take the
two-minute quiz and they'll match you to
a customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life I have a ten
year warranty and you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk-free and leave
them pick it up if you do not love it
but you got to put it back in the box so
that's not easy
we can do in pieces yeah helix is
offering up to $200 off all mattress
orders for our listeners at helix comm
slash dollop that's helix sleep sorry I
said that wrong helix is offering up to
$200 off all our mattress orders for our
listeners at helix sleep comm slash
dollop that's helix sleep dot-com slash
dollop for up to $200 off you can't
actually cut it up and put it back in
that was it Joe yeah so don't do that
Rossler brought to you by stamps comm
you guys know how I feel by stamps calm
stamps calm you know I don't have to go
to the post office anymore yeah I miss
Sheila
oh wait some your talks sure but it's
time to let that go right more
convenience stamp stops calm you can do
anything you do at the post I was right
from your computer plus stamps calm
gives you something you can't get at the
post office big discounts on postage
yeah it is it's just it just makes
everything super easy I I weigh
everything on the scale to give you you
can buy all stamps on your computer
right there and then you just put all
the put the print it up on your computer
put it on the package weep mailman comes
there it goes there it is that's it it's
that easy I just said is that it's that
easy
stamps.com brings all the services the
most I was right your computer whether
you're a small office setting invoices
and online sellers shipping out products
or even a warehouse sending thousands of
the packages a day stamps.com can handle
it all with ease miss nan stock on you
get five cents off every first-class
stamp it up to 40% off Priority Mail not
to mention it's a fraction of the cost
of
expensive postage meters so no-brainer
saves you time and money you know that
let's do it okay it's now 1 over 700 a
thousand small businesses already used
stamps calm so give yourself a
resolution you can actually keep this
here stop going to the post office and
go to stamps.com in stead there's no
risk and with our promo code dollop you
can get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus postage free
postage and a digital scale no long term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps comm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
dollop that stamps.com promo code dollop
stamps calm and never go to the post
office again there it is you okay yeah
okay we're also brought to you by the
great courses plus yes now I really have
been enjoying the great because I am I
don't know if you know this but I like
history yeah really yeah same grasp of
you're a huge history guy love it so
I've been watching a lot of the great
courses plus history stuff which I have
going they got a bunch of history stuff
they got all kinds of stuff
it's a streaming service you have the
freedom to learn more about virtually
any topic not just the basics but you
can like you can really master topic and
then you can pretend you're smarty pants
at the smarty pants party which is all
you really need
that's right that's just enough go to
smarty pants parties that's right and
then and then just spout fact yeah with
the great course plus there's unlimited
access to thousands of lectures on
topics like American presidents the
cosmos travel photography even
Mediterranean cooking which I'm sure
you're all about oh I love it the column
on there so the one I want to recommend
is the Black Death the world's most
devastating plague which I watched good
lord it's great I'm totally into that
kind of stuff most people it wasn't
great a lot of people died but I enjoyed
it so I think I think the Black Death
might have been worth it right for my
for my enjoy right ok so here's
something interesting one or something
sure the high mortality rate during the
Black Death may not have just been from
the bubonic plague some scientists think
anthrax
well anthrax is also kicking it at the
same time why having people off how just
just double down it just happened
what yeah it was a double disease
situation like getting bored the bad
boys yeah yeah so you bring that but
party people do what you dish yeah wait
until yeah
don't come in hot with that fact right
away though give yourself warm up meet
the people have a bite have a nosh
that's fair
get a cocktail that's kind of stuff you
can learn at the great courses plus get
that awesome feeling of pride that comes
with knowledge sign up for the great
courses plus they're offering our
listeners this amazing deal three months
of unlimited access for just $30 that's
only ten dollars per month but to get
this limited time offer you must sign up
today using our special URL get all the
details now at the great courses plus
comm slash dollop that's the great
courses plus.com slash dollop how'd you
know because I am noticing a pattern
yeah and then we're finally brought to
you by Squarespace which is a website
company that they do domains websites
all kinds of stuff and you know we use
them your personal well your business
website your comedy website my comedy
website our source nod cast website
podcast website all of our tour dates
everything why because we really like
Squarespace super clean easy to use yep
good analytics right yes your analytics
I'm always studying them once I get them
out of the printer that's right it's a
website you guys know website is you can
do it a lot of pie charts
so yeah that's nice you can showcase
your work you can blog you can publish
content you can sell products services
you can do it all right here on
Squarespace promote your own your
business obviously you can announce an
upcoming event like you're getting
married well I didn't want to tell
people do all kinds of stuff
they have great templates that's why I
first started using Squarespace because
I like how all the templates look and
it's easy which is really the most
important thing
would be the part that I gravitated
toward that's right yes
so check out squarespace.com slash
dollop for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code
dollop to save 10% off your first
purchase of a domain or website boom
bada bing mmm the the pictures you
posted of yourself headshots oh you
little scam Tennessee Williams presents
Dave Anthony I had my time
yeah Miami used to be a young man you
drinking a coke Dave Dave underscore
Anthony underscore at Instagram if you
want to see my old headshot Oh starting
when I was about 20 to tell you what you
get that guy laying face down on a
mattress for me and look out
i'ma coming aboard skipper excuse me
permission to do whatever I wanted
may 1st 1830 ok year by Lord Jesus
Christ yeah maybe this we need to start
again Mary Harris may have been born on
that day too devout Roman Catholics
Richard Harris and Ellen at caught her
in County Cork Ireland wait what's going
on we're not sure of her birthday okay
they lived in a small village described
as quote a poor small irregular village
that had 12 buildings in total this is
just and this time my basic vision of
Ireland
that's not one town I mean yeah that's
we got 12 buildings
we're a city where we need to be
respected we'll need a 12th building
after Mary they had four more kids
there's very little record of Mary's
early life we don't we just okay Irish
peasantry United and rebellions against
landowners during the 1830s and 1840s
sure Mary's father and grandfather
joined the fight okay I jumped in that
[ __ ] sure Kathy Irish Sean so they would
set fire to rent collector and landlord
owned buildings okay or free fellow
peasants that were imprisoned by the
British I'm all for 100% onboard right
the British sent occupying forces when
that was happening
the liberators liberators when Mary was
- her grandfather was arrested and
hanged Jesus that's yeah well you don't
remember that your - right yeah but you
absorb the trauma in a way that's
probably not it's not cool I mean you
put is not like wait remember today I
saw it but she's like why am I so
nervous around authorities when she was
five her father her father her father
was put on a list of rebels who were to
be captured and sentenced to death
good lord so British soldiers came
entered their home and tore their home
apart looking for her father but he was
already I was shipped to America okay
with his twelve-year-old son Richard jr.
okay just take the one kid it has your
name I wouldn't take any other ones
right you just want the one that's I'm
also guessing there's probably a gender
favorability at play yeah that's yeah
also the 12 girl can work yeah well I'm
like in this area you were like I'm
sorry but you're a girl so that's the
end of our race
that's actually the end of our
conversation okay so I have a good life
you were so close if you had an Audi /
if you had an Audi they put it in yeah
so sorry - it locks pushing her out an
open door there you go you're off you go
Rhonda Ward's the city a little bit you
see those 12 buildings yet go inside one
of those it's time to figure no there'll
be no yawning are you crying
oh well that's allowed that was expected
I'm surprised the games are late
all right I'm shutting the door go to
one of those 12 buildings go to one of
those 12 buildings now get a lie
go and hurry up god she's really not
moving out there is she she's really
standing I'm not caving in America
laying afraid he worked railroad
construction and save money until you
had enough to bring his entire family
over oh oh who somehow all survived the
family who has that ever happened that's
the first I survived the boat I I mean
yeah my family survived it but I'm here
relax look you had cute head shot settle
down uh so once in America the Harrisons
moved to Toronto okay they're like [ __ ]
America sure sure and then Mary became
the first Harris to graduate from high
school okay
she attended a Teachers College and got
a job teaching in a convent in Michigan
when she was 23 all right but she hated
the job and after years she quit and
went to Chicago to become a dressmaker
okay and she said quote she preferred it
preferred sewing to bossing little
children sure I completely get that I do
too something awful yeah I used to
children's birthday parties that was
what I would think two dresses don't
talk back yeah yep yeah I shouldn't yeah
in 1861 she moved to Memphis and met
George Eve Jones all right yeah what is
so you're knowing not is that there's
been some sort of sexual interaction
yeah Twix the two think so so a little
fornication we got married two months
later racist the Civil War started right
after the source okay I mean it makes
you horny it really does it lewd they
called that the Looby war lubed a lot of
people up organically George was a
skilled iron molder who worked ten to
twelve hour days in brutal conditions
okay so it's all he's awesome he has a
great job right it does it I always
tried it like whenever you like
you know he'd have to work or you're
tired from try I do always try to think
back on what life used to be like
because you say things like that you're
like yes not so bad do 10 to 12 hours
like what are you doing like I'm wearing
with the hot iron all day what did you
do like uh I got a
gave me a free lunch and well the plane
was just delighted the plane was delayed
45 minutes which just kind of throws and
then the [ __ ] internet which was your
routine and then they didn't have the
internet probably working he championed
workers rights and was an active member
of the National Union of iron motors so
he should be put to death
yes and this is out Mary was introduced
trade unions George supported them and
Mary stayed home to take care of their
firstborn child okay the Civil War was
raging Mary and Joe was Marin George
against slavery but you know they didn't
really talk about it because they're in
Memphis right keep that on the on the
down right when the war ended in 1865
they had four kids three girls and a boy
but they were the whole war they're just
[ __ ] yeah yeah post-war
industrialization took off many
Americans but they had a north-south
battle of their own I don't get that
catch my drift I don't the two of them
had a battle at her Bunker Hill follow
my do not it appears that he attacked
from the front and the Battle of well uh
finished in the cave if you follow my
meaning they don't I'm trying to say
that the gentlemen it's very sick it's a
he used a swinging door technique but he
penetrated her battle lines if you catch
the drift I'm hoping you will finally
catch because it's been taking a while
for you to seemingly click into my in
your window if you will and you will I
don't
God did they were [ __ ] no I don't
think so
yeah my god so I don't think that's true
so they had three girls and a boy
many Americans became factory workers at
this time and George started traveling
and organizing workers across the u.s.
he was a [ __ ] Union guy okay in 1867
Memphis had a very rainy spring followed
by a very hot summer sure means
mosquitoes skeeters skeeters which leads
to something called yellow fever TVs yes
so there's a Vivi's epidemic okay racist
southerners blamed immigrants calling it
a quote The Strangers disease sure of
course who else could be doing this
they've have they clearly they are just
they bring that they just bring death
with them that's right obviously the one
thing people fled the city and
working-class people had to stay behind
work and risk their lives and goodbye to
that scenario that's right so the the
city tries to do what it can to stop the
spread of the disease in different ways
they naturally they set barrels of tar
on fire in the streets yes
helping to contain the disease in the
plumes of toxic smoke yeah yeah that was
to spread chemical disinfectants yes so
the theory here is yes that's plenty I
don't even think I need to walk through
it it's called yeah it's an animated
theory yeah it makes sense yes obviously
tars stopped so many and yes if you
picture a pie cooling on the windowsill
those sort of stink that's right but
with tar tar barrels yeah good guys if
you don't want it get your head over it
take a poll people all over Memphis held
sponges to their noses to avoid inhaling
they burned the bedclothes of the dead
victims which polluted the air even more
so they're putting actually putting it
out it's airborne now from us oh we've
found a way to make the yellow fever
airborne over weeks Mary watched her
four children and then George died oh no
you know I was coming no you did though
and you were playing along you were
having a good old time yeah you have no
heart quote all about my house I could
hear the weeping and the cries of
delirium at 32 Mary was a widow with no
children when just a couple months ago
she had four kids how was yellow fever
transferred mosquitoes so they all
independently would have been bitten by
the night you know she just didn't I
don't say for sure but I believe it's
you know because mosquitoes can bite
repeat is sure so you know they bite you
and then they fly it over one plus they
were just like oh get out of here I'm
trying to focus on getting the
immigrants out of here they're getting
assets right you're killing immigrants
oh you can't kill them
you know you're busy yeah your hands are
tied so the Union George's Union paid
for the family's funeral expenses Mary
spent months then as a volunteer nurse
helping families tend to their sake
she's probably just like just kill me
with this for anything she didn't get
sick in December the cold killed the
mosquitoes and the plague and it okay I
don't know what you immigrants stopped
doing once snow started falling but
stick to not doing it yeah yeah you
understand yeah yeah I yeah I get that
white people are [ __ ] we know that it
was you the whole time stupid what we
know that it was you the whole time sure
yep so I don't know why you guys came to
an understanding and you were gonna stop
giving us all the yellow fever yeah
but we're happy what we're still
watching you have you considered that
you might be idiots we considered
everything and that theory held a lot of
weight for some of us but we just
couldn't put the pieces together I don't
know what was standing in our way we
just get so distracted
it makes our minds hurt when we try to
put well you're making my mind right now
like a spicy meatball
you got a kid stay mad at you Luigi you
are terrific you're one of the good ones
so Mary when I went to Chicago with a
little money from George's Union that
they had raised the supporter and she
opened a dress making shop okay and
quickly built an upper-class client base
okay
her business flourished but she was
still deeply affected by the lives of
the poor her autobiography quote often
while sewing for the Lords and barons
who lived in magnificent houses along
the Lake Shore Drive I would look out
the plate-glass windows and see the poor
shivering wretches jobless and hungry
walking along the frozen lake front the
contrast of their condition with that of
the tropical comfort of the people for
whom I sewed was painful to me my
employer seemed neither to notice nor
care and then I wrote parasite and thank
God things have changed yeah and and
we've moved past
yes as human beings we were like that's
wrong this is an impossible position to
empathize yeahthere's
yeah this is not applicable no October
8th I mean think all the Texas Jeff
Bezos people I know and let's keep dawn
it was great though he gave $600,000 to
charity to the Australia it's very very
which is really great because he's worth
yeah five hundred billion dollars yeah
really great it was essentially a penny
till notice it not even if he'd been a
penny in half October and she does he
does I know October 8 1871 the Great
Chicago Fire burned the city of Chicago
they should have just called it the big
Chicago fire instead of the great it
gives it that was pretty great yeah
there's you know what I mean it's just
like man that was great
like no Dan that's great this is great
fire I think we the cult the greater the
fantastic yeah I like that really good
well call it a really great fire I can't
think of any other names yeah it was
great well awesome fire alright I'm good
with it his fires [ __ ] stupendous hey
Luigi get out of here out of the ouija
may fled to the lakeshore and waited out
the fire for a day and a half over 300
people died 90,000 lost homes and
businesses that is great now that is
great
yeah that sounds when you hear it yeah
yeah yeah so Mary was crazy yeah Mary
fire is insane no it's a bad fire yeah
so Mary's one of them in two years she'd
now lost everything twice well at least
she's used to it
yeah really she's used to it oh I know
what happens the Delirium sitting this
is oh I cry a lot there it is just like
she'd done in Memphis she started
volunteering she was helping homeless
families relocate organizing soup
kitchens allocating donations and then
while she was doing that she would run
into Union men who had known George and
respected him and loved him and they
would help Mary stay helpful and give
her a sense of working-class solidarity
one night Mary came across an old
acquaintance he was standing at doorway
kind of guarding the doorway this
abandoned building okay she's like what
are you doing what's and I start talking
and after some discussion he goes okay
and come inside it was one of the
earliest meetings of the noble order of
the Knights of Labor a newly established
Union so you couldn't tell people you're
forming a union back then because you
meet in secret because workers who
belong to unions were blacklisted right
so they couldn't get work so if you were
farming union in you know 18 1870 you're
literally putting your life at risk so
this has never ever been a time where
the powers-that-be or the government
ever has been Pro Union no all a
constant battle - I always trying to
extinguish unions constantly yeah pretty
much in other countries they they
understand in the valuing Union right
the Union gives you the ability to you
know leverage leverage associated with
the whole group of workers at once right
like when some companies would come over
here from Europe they to set up a car
plant or whatever they build and we want
you have a union they be like knows in a
non union state but no but we were used
to yeah no I see here you said there is
enough negative I mean there's plenty of
net that's what that's why it is so
upsetting when you hear what you just
said about like right so the Knights of
Labor they're meeting in secret because
and then you get all that we get so far
and then again after you know we're
probably what like 30 or 40 years past
the union's peak essentially and and it
still is like beep like if you told
these people back then like oh and
eventually we'll be so misinformed that
people will think this is a bad thing
all right we'll see you later okay bye
so the night started in 1869 and quietly
spread across the country in cities they
accepted skilled unskilled workers from
all industries and
since except african-americans and women
but at this point the Knights are not
allowing women but Mary still
volunteered and started going to
meetings
sure so their long meetings there's a
lot of heated debates and Mary
discovered she had a natural talent for
public speaking okay and and she started
honing your speaking skills while
learning everything about the labor
movement and as we waiting for the
tornado to just kind of come and hit her
now well then the financial panic of
1873 happens which up to that point is
the worst depression the us said oh my
god are you serious yeah could you
imagine could you imagine a time in
America where all of these guys have all
the money are just speculating on a
bunch of [ __ ] and everything falls
apart and all the banks closed now did
you imagine that no yeah well no so this
is the only time it happened except for
all the other time it's a fairy tale to
me so soon 1 million people were
unemployed some cities had 25%
unemployment Wow so the railroad
industry was hit the hardest but CEOs
wanted to keep their profits okay
it's shocking yeah so they during the
Depression they increased the workers
days and decrease their pay which they
could do because there's 25 percent
unemployment right why I need a union
right well they are so many workers were
killed by collapsing trestles or
corroded boilers because because they're
the owners want to save money they're
not fixing anything it's not like we
can't find more workers that's right
when asked if he was worried his workers
were Rubel against him railroad tycoon
Jay Gould said quote I can hire one half
of the working class to kill the other
so this guy had suspenders in a cigar to
kill the other god damn it I just
thought of the most evil thing that I
could actually say that is the value of
when you get money your value of human
existence is it evaporates there are
studies that show that as you get more
wealthy you lose and
yeah your empathy is drink this guy has
zero or he just started out as a
psychopath but either way I think it's
bubble bass yeah so hunger and homeless
which my bath is also are go ahead I
don't think I want to go ahead no I
think I want to stop this keep going at
one legs out hunger and homelessness
were wide as spread companies did
absolutely nothing to help a prominent
industry supporting minister said quote
the necessities of the great railroad
companies demanded that there should be
a reduction of wages was a dollar a day
not enough to buy bread water costs
nothing the man who cannot live on bread
and water is not fit to live oh my god
this Minister religion I mean look Jesus
turned water into wine what do you say
yeah come on oh dude he just read water
oh man ah especially I mean that that's
that's very similar to when like the
priest the priests get the jumbo jet you
know they can the priests get the
pleiades like it's a way for me to go
and spread my message it gives the part
of the parishioners now can see more a
God needed me to million dollar plane
the man who cannot live on bread and
water is not fit to live and that's my
sermon today all right
now Jimmy come up here I'm gonna piss on
your face and we're gonna hand around
the collection bins to gang throw
something in there no bread either well
your [ __ ] bread water we're a gluten
free Atkins based in 1876 unionists and
the political radicals joined forces for
the first time to establish the
workingmen's party okay
workers or striking in Martinsburg West
Virginia
you didn't need the men's in there
necessarily workers men's yeah did I say
men you did there's no but it's called
working wasn't workingmen's party yeah
but it was just men yeah sure that's
yeah so workers striking in Martinsburg
West Virginia it spreads to railroads
all across the country because they're
stopping trains right right and then
everyone starts walking off jobs all
around the country okay
president Hayes sent federal soldiers to
Pittsburgh who fired into a crowd of
20,000 killing 26 Jesus Christ the next
day riots 79 buildings at 105
locomotives were destroyed so that
turned out to be a bad idea yeah
everybody everybody yeah the solid area
of the working class had a powerful
effect on Mary quote then and there I
learned in the early part of my career
that labor must bear the cross for other
sins must be the vicarious suffer for
the wrong others do little loss but I
get this yeah yeah I mean it doesn't
make sense but I get in the late 1880s
laborers were required to work 14 to 16
hour days but they were selfish and they
wanted just an eight-hour day what yeah
that leaves them time for life I know
the nerve so unions obviously supported
it
but most of union leaders at this point
were immigrants so the demands were
dismissed as foreign or an American by
the industrialists okay wait so just
because the union leaders are immigrants
yep
and most of the union workers probably
but specifically the leaders so they
were just like well this is a foreign
ideas right a foreign or nonsense but in
America America Cowboys like to work
fourteen six in America you work in your
sleep
so Chicago's anarchist a party endorsed
the eight-hour cause at the time
anarchist very radical very violent yes
this made politicians businessman and
law enforcement even more reluctant to
negotiate for the eight-hour day sure
quote employers use the cry of anarchism
to kill the movement a person who
believed in an eight-hour working day
was an enemy to his country a traitor
an anarchist it is shocking how they are
able to still get that message out there
yeah
the foundations of government were being
not away by the anarchist rats yeah yeah
alway always
the radical this radical radical red
these radical people like it's yeah
police opened fire at a protest at the
McCormick Harvester plant in Chicago
several several killed then a meeting
was held in response in Haymarket Square
during which a bomb went off and then
cops shot into the crowd what did they
just shooting into the cruther just
sending a message and then some strikers
shot back seven cops and four workers
were killed hundreds were injured and
then the leaders of the eenz mostly on
our kiss though were arrested and hanged
even though the bombing was never linked
to the protesters sure well you don't
need no you don't need evidence and it
went off it went off yeah hang them
newspapers Civic and religious leaders
and the public blamed the violence on
labor unions and anarchists with zero
proof right of course
at least things have changed yeah of
course the Knights of Labor didn't
believe in strikes and violence so they
refused to help the wrongly charged
protesters okay a union that doesn't
believe in strikes it's a tough one not
a great they just wanted to like talk
shut up what are we gonna do go to work
all right boys all right let's do it
we live it though so Mary and many
workers felt betrayed by the Knights
Knights of Labor membership plummeted
the Haymarket affair strengthened Mary's
belief in the power of numbers and
militant activism the Knights of Labor
went from having a million to like ten
years later having a hundred thousand
okay there was a toast sure so Mayday
was recognized as a labor holiday after
this and Mary began saying it was her
birthday
okay this began a long tradition of Mary
lying about her birth and age okay
working in coal was an extremely
dangerous job magnates like Rockefeller
did everything they could to produce
without spending money sure many workers
were injured or died in accidents but
were quickly and easily replaced yeah
that's the cool thing now yeah it's the
cool thing about a guy dying on the job
yes get another guy right
mother Jones as she started calling
herself okay nicknamed a Rockefeller oil
eat John okay the United Mine Workers of
America the UMW was established in
January 1890 and Mary joined up okay
um w quickly had millions of members and
became the largest union in the country
all right part of that was due to Mary's
field organizing she spent hours talking
to families and groups getting to know
workers and provided literature on their
plans for bettering conditions john
abruzzi a young miner from pennsylvania
described his first encounter with mary
quote she came into the mine one day and
talked to us in our workplace in the
vernacular of the mines machining mine
talk right yeah she like came in she was
like fluent in mine yes someone who
understood someone who'd listened how
she got in I don't know probably just
walked in and defied anyone to stop her
when I first knew her she was in her
late a middle age a woman of medium
height very sturdily built but not fat
nice this guy's I think we got the quote
I think that we got the boy we need let
me walk through some other problems she
would take a drink with the boys and
spoke their idiom including some pretty
rough language when she was talking
about the bosses this might have been
considered a little fast in ordinary
women but the miners knew and respected
her they might think her a little queer
perhaps it was an odd kind of work for a
woman in those days but they knew she
was a good soul and a friend of those
who most lacked friends okay so she
[ __ ] hang out she drank she talked
[ __ ] right yeah yes man we're like
you're so cool yeah we think you're an
equal yeah you do swear like us she said
[ __ ] face it's pretty great another
another worker quote all this union
business sounds ordinary enough but we
picture our organizer neither male nor a
former miner but an old woman drinking
with the boys telling off colored
stories and talking you yeah
so was their speaking skills that's way
too many quote her voice was low
unpleasant with great carrying power she
didn't become shrill when she got
excited instead her voice dropped in
pitch and the intensity of it became
something he could almost feel
physically okay Mary adopted the persona
of Mother Jones okay her nurturing
spirit gave her an appealing maternal
quality she told people she was older
than she was to reinforce the the Mother
Jones image that's anime
he wore outdated black dresses and
bonnets that she sewed herself and
referred started referring to the male
workers as her boys they're my boys I'm
91 now 35 no no no I am very old oh I
just saw you last week and I know I'm
deteriorating rapidly oh I just became
92 since we started talking she's and
I'm so legit mental Oh Rob Sam no I'm
not gonna rub your legs
no yeah drink yep okay the New York
we're all reported that she was building
her own model of motherhood quote it is
a big brood she mothers a big toilsome
troublesome brood scattered all over the
face of the land how does she do it by
the greatest of all powers the power of
love she loves her boys she teaches them
to love her this is like a sitcom but
also like a mother she knows how to make
her children behave Thursday
as Mary leaned into the role of Mother
Jones more and more she created a legend
around herself she kept her past obscure
so people did not know who she was
before she became Mother Jones and Mary
Jones ceased to exist okay on July 4th
1897 the UMW called the nationwide
strike of soft coal workers what after
they're asked to take a 20% pay cut Wow
guys 20% less money terrible this job's
already home this is impossible you
barely pay as you overworked as we have
nothing I haven't stopped my offer
okay our more work know what that's
worse more [ __ ] but now you're part
of a team no we've always been part of a
team we all love each other we hate you
but here's the deal though if you take
less money you're doing more team
working we understand the concept it's
stupid and worthy through a team player
you can't take 20% of our money we don't
have anything and one of you will get
you're gonna be named employee of the
month well you didn't tell us that part
and what comes with that is we put a
plaque up in the coalmine we've seen it
we've all wanted our face up there we're
in yes that is crazy and by the way I'm
sure the yes the ability to actually get
people to listen to these strikes or
things like that is what we just
completely no it's yeah we do no longer
have that I mean it's been happening the
fast-food workers the 15 that egg fight
for 15 and teachers but we need a mass
walkout teachers have done well yep yes
so tens is the thousands walk in the
strike but the men and their families
had to be fed and housed during the
strike obviously
so mother Jones went to western
Pennsylvania to help from the Pittsburgh
Daily Post quote she was given a rousing
reception she advanced to the edge of
the platform and listened to the noisy
approval of the crowd with a smile of
satisfaction someone in the gathering
shouted hats off and in an instant every
head was uncovered hello my lord Dave I
need to lay down
she spoke quote I see that Liberty is
not dead this gathering is a protest of
the army of toilers against the law by
injunction someday this army will rise
up in its might and turn the tables army
of toilers is fantastic yes she's a good
[ __ ] speaker I wish that there was an
army of toilers wolf she brought it
during the strike she convinced farmers
to donate food she organized escorts for
wagons delivering supplies now I don't
know why they'd want sex workers with
them Hey and she gave sweet ham with the
wagon tonight and she gave speeches to
fire up workers and then once everything
was set up at a place she would move on
to another other mining counties and do
the same things
she's franchising [ __ ] organizing all
these workers sure or franchising as you
call it she was getting more and more
attention Red Lobster that's right thank
you
The Tennessean on September 4th 1897
quote Mother Jones is a brave woman she
left her home in Chicago some time ago
to visit the scene of miners strikes but
with all this Miss Jones is a womanly
woman when the reporter called on her
yesterday she had to excuse herself for
a few moments for at the time she was
engaged in curling her hair she's still
a woman gentlemen I know you're getting
scared but she is still a woman we want
to see the penis her heart was always in
West Virginia though where the miners
had it worst also a lot of Irish miners
there I'm quote the man the man or woman
who would witness such scenes as I have
witnessed in West Virginia wouldn't
betray God Almighty if he betrayed those
people West Virginia mines were in
remote areas and coal companies built
company towns which we all know are
awesome yes they control everything the
doctor the school nurses mayor city
council judiciary police preachers most
workers and their families living
company housing and we're paid in script
company money they can use the company
stores this force to buy on credit and
then they are trapped in an endless
cycle of debt
I mean this is going on in places in
America crazy I mean it was like 10-15
years ago that there was happening in
orange orange farms in Florida they
still had [ __ ] script and company
stars and that's so crazy yeah so forces
managed to buy credit more debt more
debt companies do not let minors shop
elsewhere even though they didn't have
real money to shop elsewhere if you
figure it out you still can so West
Virginia's mines had the worst working
conditions owners spent less on safety
than any other state they didn't follow
any laws great there's a state law that
bans scripts the ban on child labor a
ban on safety measures that blew all
that off West Virginia mines had the
highest death rate in the u.s. if a
worker said anything bad about the
company he'd just be fired and replaced
immediately and in 1987 sorry in 1897
Mother Jones came to organize several
counties in to hold large rallies in
Charleston but armed guards stopped her
so she went door-to-door to talk to the
families in the Union men a fellow
organizer said she was good with
foreign-born laborers who didn't speak
much English she'd communicate with them
quote through a combination of broken
English hand gestures and French
classics French classics right
oh okay French class we got to bring
that back that's great the [ __ ] best
you know that guy I like his stuff but
he drops a lot of the French class
French classics yeah that's that's a
thing that's got to be yeah the Marx
Brothers movie she used Irish humor and
told jokes about company bosses to
lighten the mood she also spoke she
talked [ __ ] about priests and ministers
who took corporate bribes and said quote
labor must be its own religion she
traveled with a band called the mother
jones band that's no Dave I've liked
everything so far but now I've I found
something I love I couldn't find
anything else about the mother job but
the mother jones band was the thing i'm
gonna picture it as funk based effect
okay
yeah okay the three bass player yeah
yeah I'm gonna picture the p-funk yeah
that's right in a picture okay she held
that miners contracts and claim quote
even the Czar of Russia would be
dethroned if he attempted to enforce
such tyranny on his subjects oh yeah
that's right we're doing this our Russia
miners began calling themselves Mother
Jones boys they kept pictures of her in
their in their homes as if she were a
patron saint you know she's 190 she
wasn't she wasn't always too kind she
scolded some miners for being cowards
telling them if they were afraid to
fight then she would continue alone she
went wherever she was needed funded by
the UMW and socialists she helped
striking garment workers in Chicago
bottle washers in Milwaukee breweries
Pittsburgh steel workers El Paso
streetcar operators Cal calment copper
miners and tons more from a Boston
Herald the article on West Virgina
strikes in 1901 quote so the old lady is
standing very quietly in her deep
far-reaching voice painted a picture of
a life of a miner from his boyhood to
his old age it was a vivid picture you
pity yourself she said but you do not
pity your brothers or you would stand
together to help one another and then
she called him them to awaken their
minds and as she see she ceased speaking
and many women looked at each other with
shame faces for almost everyone had been
weeping Wow she's a [ __ ] speaker
Jesus yeah she brought the [ __ ] yeah
AGame always relax you're getting a
little intense okay okay a 1902 mother
Jones was leading a rally from a
platform when the state marshals
appeared in the distance here we go
finally we found a law you broke that we
just wrote you're a woman talking it's
not okay
she shot a quote goodbye boys I'm under
arrest don't surrender no he was
arrested at her trial the judge lectured
her what is she being arrested for yeah
I mean did we just a restaurant don't
jumped-up charges okay so the judge
lecture lectures are saying she had
quote strayed from the lines and paths
which the all-wise being intended her
sex to pursue oh my lord this guy yes I
mean he's really checking a lot of the
boxes of wrong angles oh did I did I
stray from the line when my family died
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I made babies and
then they all died and I decided to kick
ass instead the the idea that you're
using an invisible deity to tell you
about what gender means yeah well now
come on was a fake man in the sky hey
you know what God do you know God God
was very clear he says you should just
be [ __ ] you know you're here to cook
and [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] if you're that's
the whole last part of the Bible read
revelations if you're not [ __ ] that
you should be cooking if you're not
cooker than you should be [ __ ] you
know cooking and [ __ ] you should be
dead that's right he also said that
there were many charities that she could
engage in of a lawful character that
would be more in keeping with what we
have been taught and what experience has
shown to be the true sphere of womanhood
yes thank you we could do like a charity
thing where she helps babies yeah for
cookies some sort of pie thing yeah yeah
pie charity that's right all right some
other Jones listen Judah oven mitts for
a year some other Joe's listened and
then when he was done talking she called
the judges gab and then she told him she
would do it all over again and then in a
very gentle voice she noted how old they
both were and suggested they might be
friends in death one day Wow he was like
what the hell believe she's told them
she would see him in hell yes the
courtroom audience flipped out enjoyed
it very much yeah
West Virginia District Attorney a Reese
Blizzard's closing statement that's a
[ __ ] name I'm actually a weathermen
God how could I not be weathermen yet
miss Reese Blizzard if only he was
closing statement quote there sits the
most dangerous woman in America she
comes in a state where peace and
prosperity reigns
crooks her finger and 20,000 contented
men lay down their tools and walk out
all right
you can listen to me on what a quick
strike tragedy in this state is my last
name is blizzard I rest my case rest
yeah that doesn't make sense
legitimately doesn't make stem tried so
hard but I know there's a line let me
take over let me tell you I'm Bobby
Raines and I'm something Blizzard were
the weather lawyers we rest our case yes
the case I felt like I had something and
I stood up and I said my name you had
nothing I did I do literally stood up
said your name but then I started
thinking that your name and then I
always started thinking of the weather
and I'm like why am I thinking of the
weather right now I remember and we
don't know whether you say guilty or not
guilty but how's weather spelled in
there
wrap it up by oh my god that's so as
hell here's what I think we should do
you need to kill each other I think we
need to go out of the courtroom an exam
I have a gun you have a gun let's just
shoot each other yes let's go now let's
go now yep so so she's she's not
innocent she's released
okay so 1897 1904 strikes significantly
improved miners standard of living in
workplace safety over those years okay
but John's was also very successful
bringing workers wives into the movement
nice she organized what she called the
mop and broom brigades Oh like what okay
so there were mothers and wives who
stood at the entrance to a mine where a
strike was happening and they would be
there 24 hours a day there was always
wives or moms they're usually they would
always try to have a baby in their arms
okay
and then they would shame any non
striking workers trying to go in so
they're like shame Barker's yeah Wow oh
where are you going
I've got to go to work yeah you had this
little guy here do you want to say hi
yes all right I got in four days we
should know why why because my husband
he's working this mine oh look I can
he's on strike I'm sorry about though oh
wait he's dying oh my god is he dying
it looks like he's dying you know why oh
yeah you're killing him yeah oh you're
killing him come in for a minute okay
just go ahead and leave okay okay Popeye
damn it yeah
damn it yeah then another one it's a
cute one I know you're gonna tell me
it's dying I'm not falling for it
yeah he died oh my god I'll go in just
for a minute so uh so that worked that
was a great tactic yeah having women as
part of the labor movement was very
unusual for the time Mother Jones quote
why wouldn't a woman be able to discuss
mine affairs who has a better right has
she not given birth has she not raised
you and cared for you has she not
struggled along for you does she not
today when you come home covered with
corporation suit have hot soap and water
and towels ready for you does she not
have your supper ready for you and your
clean clothes ready for you so old old
thinking there a little bit she makes a
good point
while mother Jones advocated for the
inclusion of women she had a
contradictory stance on women's rights
hmm she was against female suffrage
interesting okay and argued quote you
don't know what the towels [ __ ] your
quote you don't need the vote to raise
hell you don't well but she got dot dot
but wouldn't it be great to have it
what about both just in case
does the case democracy existed she
believed it was more important to
liberate the entire working class before
moving on to gender issues I think we
didn't walk and chew gum but okay I
here's what I think she's saying I think
that she's seeing middle-class women and
upper-class women fighting for what they
want and not giving a [ __ ] about poor
people
splitting the movement so I so that's
what that's what she's saying and she
got a really negative obviously
inevitably attacked for this but you see
her point when she's dealing with
starving people versus people who want
to vote I think that it's a very
applicable to today when like I think
people who are as a aware realize there
is one issue and that's the only issue
that matters but also let's do this
other stuff what about this stuff yeah
like that's terrible but she was
attacked by suffragettes and accused of
being anti women's rights um other Jones
quote I am NOT anti to anything which
brings freedom to my class she thought
wives played an important role as
nurturers and motivators for striking
men but not its workers she's thought
young girls working in mills were being
robbed and demoralized
so quote working men should earn a wage
that would allow women to stay at home
to care for the kids so it's a little
old thinking you know it's I get what
she's saying right I also think you can
fight for both things yes but again the
upper class women are not fighting for
poor people to have a decent living wage
they're fighting for the vote yeah so
it's complicated
she wasn't great on race this is like
we're digging up her old tweets
[Laughter]
mother jones always preached racial
inclusivity except she was against
Chinese immigration what I can't how
does that all the races should be
working in the not the Chinese not the
Chinese all of the races it's not my
children except those Devils it's not
even like it's just funny because that's
so crazy how do you well remember so
we've we've talked about this in the
other episode I mean the Chinese you
look at your brother and your sister
next to you and that's the Chinese then
ask them again to leave we've been very
clear you're not welcome here but
everyone else we are all one we are all
united is that a Chinese guy a scapegoat
sir so remember this is when you know
the strikes the the railroad kingpins
not in Chinese right specifically to
[ __ ] over the striking workers so yeah
again but that's how capitalist play
play everyone against each other that's
how they keep their money but you're
saying that the probability that she
would not have an issue with Chinese
people if they were not brought into
work undermined the strikes yeah
probably at least I would imagine okay
so she but she did fight for the Chinese
Exclusion Act quote when the Pacific was
bringing over Chinese to break the labor
movement the battle began there and I
had a hand in that Chinese agitation we
kept it up and stopped the Chinese
coming over the Union Pacific had been
bringing them over in hoards and using
them to break the labor movement which
is true but you don't blame the Chinese
people who just want jobs the true
villains are the [ __ ] yes again the
puppet master but she had a deep respect
for african-americans and what they had
been through unless they like those
Chinese people unless they come for our
jobs in June of 1903 Mother Jones went
to a textile mill in rural Philadelphia
where thousands of child workers were on
strike for better-paying conditions so
great a child strike 1903 children on
strike our children are
striking for better wages shelter in
1903 1903 children all right boys
come on these conditions are no good I
tell you about dolls now before I hit
puberty had five smoke breaks it's gonna
fall they were mostly in the early teens
but some were as young as six
Pennsylvania law banned children under
13 from working in Mills but no one
enforced it good
mother Jones deep imagine working with a
six-year-old oh god what a [ __ ] night
imagine working first of all number one
sharing works number one can I just say
the chatter oh my trying to give it
direction walking no I'll tell you go
over there do do it why but why did I
even make it like that don't ask me
another goddamn question Christ put on
your welding mask I did but I forgot it
next to my paint brush I have a
paintbrush
I got your bear brushes shadow carrots
at paint brushes
yeah ap the one guy you went over there
and then you have it made a dinosaur
will you shut up on the welding mask and
put down the paper pusher not a [ __ ]
painter I want to show you my drawings
and then I put out the welder's mask I
don't want to see your drawings I got
hot in there this is the airplane
yeah kept putting stired again I are you
held my hand I don't want to I Love You
mr. Jesus I'm your Foreman how is it
work it's really bad fire some of these
kids it's really bad I finally feel like
I'm running a kindergarten our numbers
kids understand Mother Jones quote six
and seven-year-olds start their workday
at 5:30 a.m. taking their scanty lunch
at noon working at 7 p.m. then returning
home to a rushed dinner
sleep until the factory whistle blew
again in the morning baby to diapers a
practice [ __ ] my pants of budge tomorrow
I haven't seen mothers take their babies
and slap cold water in their face to
wake the poor little thing like a
six-year-old i watch them all day long
attending to dangerous machinery I've
seen their helpless limbs torn off and
then when they are disabled and of no
more use to the master thrown out to die
we're gonna another four-year-old that
was missing an arm by oh my god it's
just when you see people say that
socialism has never died anything I
really want to take a child's arm and
beat them with it oh my god her
attention switched to child labour after
witnessing this huh but the mills blew
off all of Mother Jones demands they
like it
frustrated Mother Jones decided on
another tactic quote I'm going to show
Wall Street the flesh and blood from
which it squeezes its wealth oh boy
July 7th over 300 children and adults
began to march to President Theodore
Roosevelt's summer home on Long Island
from Philadelphia we strike it was hot
and many were too tired to March locals
gave food and lodging as they walked
along the coast in Princeton New Jersey
mother Jones was asked to speak on
campus she pointed at a twelve-year-old
boy
quote here's a textbook on economics he
gets three dollars a week and his sister
who was 14 gets six dollars they work in
a carpet factory ten hours a day while
the children of the rich are getting
their higher education and then she
glared at each and every student in the
crowd which just 45 minutes later time
to continue speaking that is so great I
mean I'm also truly like being
confronted with that like I wish we
could be confronted that yeah
simply today a week later the striking
kids arrived in New York City they were
greeted by thousands of supporters the
Social Democratic Party offered their
headquarters as a space for them to you
know stay whatever
I ordered yeah she took the kids to
Coney Island where she put them in cages
as like a symbolic I couldn't find more
about this but I just rather she she put
them in like metal cages very fine line
actually caging children and then the
kids also got taken to the circus that
was nice a really fun strike yeah the
kids have been traveling for four weeks
now
they were very tired they walked they
walk from Philadelphia to New York and
in the heat yeah
Mother Jones took three kids and four
Union men to President Theodore
Roosevelt's Oyster Bay mansion but they
were stopped at the gates and told quote
the president has nothing to do with
child labor what not my issue lady
you're thinking of another Roosevelt
bullae yeah the president never
responded he's just got kid like he's
got a lion head on the wall next like a
child's hand the trophy room
he never responds and then soon a coal
strike in Colorado pulled Mother Jones
away and the children marched back to
Philadelphia and went back to work can
we get a cab
no they lost but the mill children
strike published publicized child labor
and pressured politicians to do
something which they didn't do because
it would take another 36 years for the
federal government to ban child labor 36
years because America and capitalism are
awesome yeah between 1905 in 1912 mother
jones participated in strikes across the
country and took jobs with the Socialist
Party as a lecturer but she was getting
old and in hospital and was hospitalized
with pneumonia once still she
exaggerated her age even more and now
claimed to 185-thousand she's not gonna
be in her 80s when she was still in her
70s okay and then she started working at
mines and helping children load coal
that's the right age to start yeah
February 1913 violence broke out during
protests in though I'm gonna say this
wrong Kanawha Valley West Virginia the
governor declared a martial law and sent
the state militia to arrest strikers and
organizers so mother Jones went and she
gathered a small group and they marched
or they didn't march they got a train
heading for Charleston hoping to talk to
the governor faced him down now a rumor
started that she was coming with an army
to assassinate the governor and bomb the
Capitol building
well now Dave that's a big rumor papers
reported it as fact the Newcastle Herald
said the strikers would quote tear out
the heart of the sheriff kill the
governor and wiped the militia off the
map this is just good journalism when
Mother Jones and her miners reached the
train station they were arrested the
Fairmont West Virginian headline quote
Mother Jones
aged agitator kept in a boxcar okay she
was then taken back to kanawa Valley and
jailed she was charged with conspiracy
to murder and had to appear in a
military tribunal even though she was a
civilian arrested in a civilian area
okay he just decided to give her a
military trial yes and the beret there
you are
now she refused to recognize the
legitimate
what which is I mean that's I kind of
make sounds like it's legally right this
food court rejected that and she was
given a 20-year sentence what for
conspiracy to murder which she was never
doing Wow
you mentioned a miscarriage of justice
in America not here she's put into
solitary confinement oh there's that fun
term again she said quote I can raise
just as much hell in jail as anywhere
but 22 days later she was found quote
lying on a straw tick on the floor
carrying a temperature of 104 with very
rapid rest position
respiration and a constant cough mother
Jones had pneumonia so to say face the
governor secretly had a mother Joan sent
to hospital to recover and then after
she was recovered he was gonna put her
back in solitary but word got out and
the public was furious people demanded
her release and a congressional
investigation within a week a
congressional committee reached a West
Virginia and the industrialists were for
a second that it's can you imagine
getting a congressional investigation
into an anti-establishment figures
health within a week yeah I know I mean
that just doesn't that's not even on the
radar will happen at all possibility no
and the industrials were under so much
pressure that they were forced to
negotiate with the Union and the work
day it was reduced to nine hours
miners were allowed to buy from stores
outside the company towns the miners are
allowed to be people that's right yeah
you can be humans okay all right I'd
still enjoy your fun box but Mother
Jones remain in solitary confinement she
survived a second battle with pneumonia
and after 85 days they just let her go
okay very very weird handling of this
sentence when she arrived in New York
City she was met by a mob quote shouting
stamping hand clapping people threw
kisses to the aged agitator and flowers
at her feet she gave interviews to
reporters in which she made horribly
racist comments okie-dokie quote but in
calling for unity among American workers
she also made the most blatant racist
comment of her long career complainant
complaining of both the Japs and the
Hindus were entering the country in
large numbers and becoming a serious
menace to labor in the western states
certainly it's tough yeah it's tough
stuff
she was lush yeah yeah she went right
back to work and headed for Colorado to
organize strikers in the Colorado cold
war where she was arrested again quote
without a warrant or without any
suspicion of a crime mo J Mother Jones
was illegally held in a dungeon like
self for a month a letter she wrote
quote a let the nation know that the
great United States of America is now
holding Mother Jones incommunicado in an
underground cell surrounded by rats
tinhorn soldiers and other vermin the
public flooded the White House with
telegrams and again she was released
with no charges she testified before the
House Mines and mining committee and
urged Congress to intervene in Colorado
and Congress did absolutely nothing and
as we've talked about in a secure
episode many men would be killed in that
strike in what will become known as the
Ludlow massacre after that people
protested across the country and a
government report claimed quote there
was positive danger of a national
revolution growing out of this Colorado
strike now that's scary
can you imagine the government doing
something like
killing someone and then saying well
they were going to attack somebody nope
I can't either
not recently at least Mother Jones spoke
to President Wilson but he just offered
his sympathies and nothing more the
Union would eventually win in Colorado a
few years later mother jones opposed
World War one and American involvement
in a 1920 she made a statement opposing
the 19th amendment quote I have never
had a vote and I have raised hell all
over this country you don't need a vote
you need convictions and a voice I am
NOT a suffragist in no sense of the word
am i in favor of women's suffrage in a
long life of study of these questions I
have learned that women are out of place
in political work there already is a
great responsibility upon women
shoulders that of rearing rising
generations home training of the child
should be their task and it is the most
beautiful of tasks so here's what I like
I said I think that she's seeing richer
women fighting for the vote while being
upset that poor kids are losing the
limbs [ __ ] like that so but at the same
time yeah you know yeah you gonna do
both so yeah she's wrong yes she called
women suffrage a middle class movement
at a dinner honoring her she said quote
God Almighty made the woman and the
Rockefeller gang of thieves made the
ladies for the idle rich woman who
parades her finery before the hungry and
poverty-stricken is a modern Inquisitor
turning the thumbscrews of envy and
despair into the very vitals of those
who are in reality her sisters Jesus
Christ oh she's very good with a word
Lord but you know that's how I feel
about you know you see Hollywood
liberals whose the there's the the
actress from who's the boss the Judith
Light no Alyssa Milano Alyssa Milano a
great example I think today of what
she's talking about right
is you know yeah there's this this
they're fighting for what matters to
them and yet the the astounding poverty
like the fact that you can drive around
Los Angeles and there's where we have
seventy thousand almost people or more
and and and then fight for other things
like there there's like this blind spot
to horrific poverty that's astounding
the the that is it's very interesting
because people who are also liberally
minded think that when someone who is a
fellow liberal says you know says stuff
like this is the only issue that matters
or some of the rhetoric that comes out
these are people who have now lost such
touch with what actual people go through
that they're just like no you know
there's this is this is the way to do it
and it's like I have to feed a family
yeah like there's just not room for this
sort of thinking in my world there it's
like every day I don't know why he
particularly drives me crazy but every
time Donny Deutsch talks I want to he's
[ __ ] awful he's the worst but he's
also a liberal who has no concept of
what's happening no concept and never
has and people who have never had a
concept of what it's like to struggle or
need help or just need safety nets there
people who don't know that feeling
of course they don't see the matter in
that issue at all
it doesn't affect their kids it doesn't
affect their the world right around them
yeah of course so I think I think that's
what she's talking about and I think you
know that's what Martin Luther King
talked about that's what a lot of people
and with what you say about homelessness
too it is when does when do people
become violent thinkers towards homeless
versus and that is already happened it's
happening it's happening and the reason
is because the second that it starts to
make your neighborhood not as great as
it was before you
the problem done I mean I it's like bees
like everybody I'm sorry
it's like bees okay everybody you know
save the bees bees are dying like I see
bees all the time you know you see bees
these like dazed States yeah and you're
like gotta save the bees the bees are
everything Einstein said if the bees go
away we die
I had my apartment infested by bees once
and he killed them I mean you want you
are like get I don't care get the bees
like I can't live in a hive you know
what I mean
so it's like the second that that you
know there is yeah yeah yeah yeah I
guess so it's like it's like the bees
Mother Jones wrote an autobiography in
1923 and her timeline events was very
off historians believe the book cannot
be trusted or used as a factual
reference she celebrated her 100th
birthday on May 1st 1930 and died does
this yeah yeah she died six months later
on November 30th 1939 130th probably 93
years old they think okay thousands
attended her memorial service in DC she
was buried where she wanted to be in
Mount Olive Illinois in the Union miners
Cemetery where a lot of miners who have
been killed are buried she's known for
the phrase pray for the dead and fight
like hell for the living and her
magazine is Mother Jones is named after
her oh you can read a lot of stuff there
that will make you upset right
you know the editor complains about
homeless people in San Francisco
complains about them yeah on Twitter and
you're like you're the problem with
journalism is that you listen a lot of
prominent sure I mean not all but a lot
of prominent journalists now are also
rich super rich so and that's the same
with the news when you watch media and
you consume your news through the
quote-unquote personality based news
yeah these are millionaires they're
millionaires millionaires all
millionaires
all millionaires telling you why you
shouldn't care about issues that seem
important to you yeah yeah it's pretty
great yeah the ability to make us ignore
our own instinct
- it's pretty awesome sources Mother
Jones and the March of the milk children
by penny
Coleman Mother Jones the most dangerous
woman in America by Elliott Gorn the
importance of Mother Jones Madeleine
Horton the speeches and writings of
Mother Jones well that's just by Mother
Jones and then Mother Jones a fierce
fighter for workers rights
Judith Pinkerton Josephson Judith I
would lose the middle name yeah yeah so
she's a badass
and yes it's the racism self is
upsetting this yes the suffragists stuff
is a bummer but you know you got it you
got a there's just some people you gotta
go she she did a lot for someone yeah
and you can take the good and use the
good yeah hopefully it is I mean as we
know that like unions are it's so
important to have oh it turns out
without you your country turns into
ocean giant [ __ ] [ __ ] pile and again
it is they are anytime that knot gets
tied tightly they are pulling on the
thread again they miss constant we're
never a constant constant constant
battle to make you believe you can trust
them and don't need a union yep and
that's why people in Ayers and Amazon
warehouses are walking on broken feet
yeah yes and you're not allowed to like
I mean yes there there is a story that
I've contemplated doing which is about
of I don't remember the name of the
company but it's a factory in in the
south and it's literally just like
people getting their arms ripped off all
the time and like horrific injuries
because there's no union and of course
the government the logo is not doesn't
give a [ __ ] about OSHA regulations yeah
and they're letting him do and it's
literally people getting maimed all the
[ __ ] time because they need to make
an order this doesn't seem comedic Lee
fruitful to you
but also and they are this stuff now
that's happening with protest laws and
stuff they're starting I mean that [ __ ]
is they're preparing for climate change
yes and but it is you know don't tell
anybody
it's illegal to protest well hey I hate
to tell that it's illegal to protest the
climate specifically I hate to tell them
but kids our kids are being raised on
computers so if you you want to stop
protest you better take all their
computers at some point thing is start
[ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah once I mean truly
like yeah it'll be a different it's
gonna be different
mm-hmm it'll be a reboot and we love
reboot
so it'll be great is there anything else
we wanted to talk about David no good
luck to everyone Australia yes truly and
there are a lot of great charities to
donate to tough up guys have a [ __ ] yeah
me well and Charlie from Toph up have
one there's the Red Cross and then the
yeah like I said they're the place that
I think I'm going to donate cool is yeah
it's Colin like animals you know because
that [ __ ] the [ __ ] wombats well and
talk no did you hear about the one
that's what the wombats were you know
woman's have dens that they hide from
fires in they were running out and
guiding other animals into their death
oh my god
that's crazy yeah I mean and in
Australia like they're still while this
is all going on pushing coal new oil I
mean this now we are literally in the
gif of the dog and the house on fire
saying it's fine yeah I mean it is
[ __ ] crazy like the fact that it's
just ultimate corruption I mean I and
and we're there and most most countries
are too I mean we are just this well the
change will be rapid and they won't know
what hit them
basically what do you mean will change
people yeah people oh you only take so
much and then oh and then the
switches when the switch flip oh yeah oh
yeah all the Colo people are no well
even when you're talking about the you
know like the ability to mobilize people
on the level that she did in this story
I'm like that's impossible
it's it is I mean we should be in the
streets now yeah we will but we will I
will have no choice you know yeah and
it'll be really fun and that
temperatures will be it'll be nice times
to be outside when you got a press these
things that's right which is part of the
problem in Australia too it's so
polluted that it's hard to you know
activism does suffer under yeah yeah
yeah I mean that's a clearly a problem
all right you have fun in Australia
thanks I know we'll do one more podcast
before then Yeah right
this week yeah when does this one come
out tomorrow all right gonna drop this
one tomorrow Aaron yeah it's hot drop it
all right well this I mean let's do the
regular wrap out all right everybody
this has been for Dave Anthony this is
Gareth Reynolds saying hey if you think
American history is [ __ ] up how about
we do it nine more times
alright that's either the podcast on
social media thanks so much everybody
good night America